[Music]
hello it was announced at facebook
bought company Occulus it was kind of a
big deal one because it was a lot of
money sort of legitimizing VR in a way
but it also scared a lot of people
because I feel have problems with
facebook but one of the things that they
were planning on doing was making
virtual reality a very social tool and I
got a chance to try to III love it you
just got a chance to try it today sure
to describe to me just the base scenario
what was happen man okay so basically I
was standing in a room with Sam proofing
ended it was a square room and I was
standing in right in the middle and they
popped the oculus onto my head and it's
not like speakers right it's got this
way headphones right here and then I
can't see anything at this stage and
they asked me to put my hands out and
they put something on to my hands I have
no idea what these things are but they
fit nice and then I basically like beam
up and I'm in this world alright i'm
standing on what i can see i must be a
pair of hands and a face because there's
somebody across from me and then they
start talking to me yeah and then i
realize that they're in the room behind
and we're actually playing together
so the basis for this whole thing is
that you are in a virtual space with
somebody but in actuality you guys are
in separate locations right so and
essentially what you're accomplishing is
you have created this little scenario
that doesn't exist with any other
technology yes I don't think it's
possible any other way to really
interact like you were in 3d space like
what were some of the things you guys
are doing because I know my favorite was
like lighting fireworks and throwing
them and catching them and stuff like
yes so basically but with these things
in my hands I don't even know what they
are but they work which feels really
strange because I'm basically like I'm
squeezing my hands on like my hands are
turning into face they're in doing it
yeah the suit and I'm like pointing on
my hand is pointing and I'm doing like
thumbs up and like what I'm doing
basically is like picking up objects are
picking up cuboids you know putting up
worked angles things piling them up like
playing anti Jenga basically and and
then it's like oh we can play with all
these other things she's a ball and like
I'll throw the ball and then he catches
it then he throws it back I'm like right
like okay this doesn't feel like I'm
playing a video game anymore this feels
like I'm actually but a physical playing
at you're not thinking about right you
just react the way you would in normal
life yeah Krista was behind the camera
nap we had a demo afterwards and I won't
say it's just unprompted I picked up a
robot and chucked it at him and he went
whoa yeah any cottage it was like super
super intuitive and yeah but it
basically went through a bunch of these
sort of technical presentations showing
off various different things you can do
right picking up objects to shooting
things to my favorite was there was a
slingshot yeah that is really good and
the two sparks yeah just pick the [ __ ]
it just daddy could take a boot I'm all
the funniest things that happened was at
a certain stage he brings at a ray gun
which basically door make makes you
small yeah it makes the other person
small and then I was this tiny Chris
shoot to me with the Reagan I'm this
tiny version of me yikes and he was like
being a jerk and like throwing things at
me and shoot me and stuff but I can't
move cuz I'm like tiny but then I see
the sanction also have to pick up the
slingshot right like I still use it but
now I'm like exact like 10 times as
large yeah but I'm like so I'm sure
there's all this footage of me looking
like an absolute numpty playing this
thing it was it was unbelievable it was
like it was one of those things were
like I could have described it to you
and you probably wouldn't have
any idea how it felt because it is a
feeling it is not just something that
you learn and then understand you have
to experience totally and there's a wait
it the intuitive like when I was talking
to the gentleman on the other side are
talking to Christ like the microphone on
the headset so like it just works and
when they talk there it's like a pulsing
a little ecstatic like waiting for
exactly Jenna floating head with like a
wireframe but it moves and everything
about us like head gestures to like that
I've ever like just felt like I was
talking to a human person and I think a
lot of people expect for that to feel
that way it has to look exactly like
them it has to be this yeah like perfect
representation but we are instinctively
trained to see faces in things that
don't exist right so therefore when we
have a thing that's rendered that just
sort of shares the qualities of a face
it's really easy to just sort of buy
into it and go along and then there's
this world it's like so it all just
works it's basically a physics demo but
there's all these different things gonna
be like for instance with these balls in
the corner that you smash and they
turned it into like underwater land
where like space and then suddenly
gravity works so right at the end of the
presentation he was like oh after e3 we
actually found this cool thing we can do
and he basically start spawning roman
candles I only spawns dynamite and what
he's going to do is smash the space ball
right as they go off and it's going to
be a glorious fire at the same space but
I'm just standing here what he's doing
it I'm just like picking [ __ ] up and
throw it and I throw this thing it's
like cute and it hits this massive like
gnome who then falls and hits the space
ball before he's finished and everything
just goes fly ah whoops whoops
all your work this has disappeared and
everything just goes fly and then starts
exploding and then the space for like it
dissipates after a while you go back
into normal and it all like falls down
and I'm like oh yeah it's it's a mitt
that was just a random thing it wasn't
supposed to happen and it was amazing so
like when I try to tell people what it's
like to really experience VR is very
convincing yeah it's never about how it
feels in the moment of VR because you're
not thinking about it so much but for me
whenever I take the headset off it's
coming back to reality and the fact that
it shocks my system that I realized i'm
[ __ ] I really bought into it yeah
totally he actually believe what was
happening to me and I only know it when
I just wrenched myself out of it so fast
nothing about this felt like I was
playing a video game nobody ever we're
trying to feel convinced yes exactly
there was no me trying to buy into it
right it different [ __ ] it [ __ ]
worked yeah and that was like super
exciting you can tell it feels like one
of those moments like you nobody pick up
the wiimote for a first time we like wow
it's like that like x 100 I had a lot of
fun watching you and I knew shown some
of you so far what Danny was doing but
here's a look at just the joy that you
have about 20 minutes straight hello oh
I got his leg I got a [ __ ]
[ __ ] Oh
[Music]
hey guys blow you mad man no you're
there you go saw the picture of Socrates
oh yeah all right
[Music]
awesome sorry little dude my bad oh yeah
the bike oh that's good all right you
know what I was going to keep my hands
to myself okay I can do this I can do
this thing bro this is amazing there's
something I star so satisfying in real
life about doing this that is totally
exists here's a awesome who knows that
something like yeah I was absolutely
amazing Oh
[Music]